e
councelors ladies and gentlemen and I
welcome you all here to the meeting this
evening at the
council before we formally start this
meeting at my discretion and the absent
of father malar who unfortunately cannot
be with us here this evening I invite
counselor bbar to lead us in very short
prayer thank you
counselor thank you mayor for the
opportunity to recite a few lines from
the Holy Quran it marks an important uh
moment as it truly reflects that tra is
for everyone and this chamber represent
all communities that live in our
bahman in the name of Allah the most
compassionate most merciful Master of
the day of judgment you alone we worship
you alone we ask for help the path of
those who you have blessed not those you
are dis pleased with or those who are
astray the paragraph I've just read from
the Holy Quran is part of the five daily
prayers uh every Muslim will read this
is a very comprehensive prayer itself in
which we praise our Lord and we seek his
guidance to walk us on the right path
not just offering prayers but be benef
beneficial to the whole Humanity thank
you thank you
counselor
apologies I have received apologies for
the absence from councelor AI Kevin
Proctor and Shirley Proctor is there any
more
apologies
voting and broadcasting
information we have the use of the
microphone units in the chamber this
evening for speaking and they work by
pressing the bar on and
off please can I ask all members to
speak closely and into the microphone to
help us all to hear and to ensure the
speeches are conveyed clearly to the
broadcaster may I also appeal to
everyone to make sure that they are not
blocking the microphone with
papers should the vote be necessary this
evening I will ask for a show of
hands this meeting is also being
streamlined on the council committee
meeting YouTube
channel the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except whether are confidential
or exempt
items and this actively promotes
democratic engagement in accordance with
section 100 brackets 9 of the Local
Government Act
1972 at the outset of the meeting I am
proposing to limit speeches but please
be aware that I may
introduce I will not be proposing to
limit speeches but please be aware that
I may introduce time limits as necessary
to ensure we can get through tonight's
business thank you and can I ask you all
to to to be in your seats that's been
allocated to you which this adds
confusion thank
you item one is
minutes the first item is the minutes
and I move that the minutes of the
meeting be held on the 22nd of November
2023 be taken as read and signed as a
correct record is that seconded seconded
mayor all those in
favor uh point of order please Madame
mayor sorry
right um the minute State uh the answers
to all the questions from members uh
would be answered in writing and
circulated after the council meeting the
last one we're talking about uh I've
have yet to receive an answer uh to my
question about the heating issues at
wellgreen Primary School um and have had
no update as to when I may be likely to
receive these particular answers does
this mean the minutes currently as
agreed are not correct thank
you
thank you um we will amend the minutes
uh to reflect that there's still a
question outstanding and of course we'll
fall at all path of the meeting
also thank
you item two
announcements sir Tony lyd MP and our
former member of parliament for
Stratford you will be aware that since
the last meeting sir Tony ly serving MP
and husband to councelor Judith Li sadly
passed away on the 17th of January sir
Tony represented Stratford parliamentary
constituency between June 83 and may
1997 having been elected three
times sir Tony Lloyd born in Stratford
and became a local counselor and labor
party leader before becoming a member of
parliament for
Stratford he will be sadly missed the
council sends its condolences to
councelor Judith law
and her family who are with us here this
evening as a mark of respect I invite
the council to stand for a minute
silence in reflection of Sir to's memory
thank
you
e
thank
you his majesty the king's New Year's
honors may we take this opportunity to
recognize these citizens and persons
connected with Trafford who were named
in his majesty the king's New Year's
honors
list obes were awarded to Mr Michael
George kin from altringham for services
to music and to the community in
Liverpool Mery side and Miss Katie
Galler from Herston for services to
digital technology industry in the
northwest
MBE were awarded to Mr George buan from
sale for services to nuclear industry
and young
people Miss Amanda Chadwick from
Partington for services to children in
hospitals Mr John Hubert Cox from hail
for services to homeless people in
Manchester Mr Nicholas Edward Johnson
from Bowden for services to homeless
people in
Manchester and Miss Jenny Thompson from
Bolton for services to business and food
sectors the British Empire medals were
awarded to Mr Edward Everett from sale
for service of the environment and sale
Mr Daniel Herman from Balden bden from
services to education and to the
Holocaust
awareness and Mr William Ellis Nixon
from sale for services to young people
in the West
Midlands I'm sure you will join with me
in conveying the council's
congratulations to their achievements
and richly deserved
recognition does the leader of the
council wish to make any brief
announcements this evening thank you
mayor I do wish to make some brief
announcements this evening um as
colleagues will be aware it is
trafford's 50th birthday this year and
over the course of 2024 we'll be
recognizing this milestone in different
ways this will include celebrating key
people from trafford's his history and
with that in mind I would like to start
by celebrating satony Lloyd's life and
the contribution he made to Trafford at
every elected level as we've heard from
the mayor previously uh he was a
Clifford Ward counselor from 1979 to
1984 then the Member of Parliament for
Stratford from 1983 to 1997 followed by
a time as police and crime commissioner
from 2012 and interim mayor of greater
Manchester from
2015 many people from across all our
parties will have known and met Tony on
various occasions and I know we all
agree despite all political differences
that Tony was a kind decent human being
and we should see more of his like in
politics um Tony's a person one that
I've known for around 25 years it was a
real honor to get to know him in the
late 90s and throughout my time in the
council he's always been a supportive
person I know he was incredibly or is
incredibly proud of his family I know
that a few of them are watching this
evening from afar he was incredibly
proud of Judith and I remember when
Judith became the mayor of Trafford he
was beaming with pride throughout that
year to see Judith in that role and you
know I just just to see how close that
family and loving that family are is to
one of Tony's real legacies to have left
that so I know that we've all stood in
respect for Tony but there's a lot to
celebrate about his life and his
contribution to Trafford at every
elected level since the late 1970s and
we wish Judith and her family all the
love in the world at this difficult time
and I'm delighted you could be here this
evening Judith to hear
that other things I'd like to share are
that since we last met Trafford Council
has won the keep it local award at the
annual locality Awards in Bristol this
recognizes the impact our community hubs
have made since they were set up in
2020 members will have noted that I
wrote to Michael go the Secretary of
State for leveling up housing
communities back in December urging him
to bring forward a fairer funding review
of which I know we'll be discussing
later I also wrote to the chancellor
with a plea that he keeps the household
support Fund in place beyond the 31st of
March 2024 and we will be continuing to
Lobby the government around that because
that could have catastrophic
consequences for some of our most
vulnerable families in the burough if
that funding stops at the end of March
on a lighter note I was delighted to see
our first Cyclops Junction open in
December with more Junction improvements
to follow as we make life better and
safer for pedestrians and cyclists it
was also a pleasure to host the GM
active travel commissioner Dame Sarah
story earlier this week and show her our
progress with our road and Junction
improvements across the bough the deputy
leader and I visited ultr Leisure Center
to check upon the good progress being
made with this multi-million pound
investment into a brand new Leisure
Center in uh in in altringham we're
about halfway now but a lot of progress
has been made the demol demolition so
over the next year we'll see we'll see
the construction phase truly start and I
joined colleagues at another visit to
stretford Mal area to see the
regeneration work that's taking place
there multi-million pounds worth of uh
capital investment going in there to
improve the town center and make it fit
for the 21st century and also improve
the public realm with Kingsway along
there our community safety officers have
been um have been legal team and
partners have secured several closure
orders ERS over properties in the
burough in recent months this has had a
huge contribution to our efforts to
tackle crime and antisocial Behavior it
takes a lot of work but it makes a big
difference if we can close down
buildings that are causing a real issue
and I know that we've had an issue with
Ora Court in Old Trafford and other
buildings across the bough where a lot
of joint partnership workers has has
brought them to closure it was also
great to see the Waterside Arts first
prism Festival last November first time
this event was on but incredibly in
successful and S looked am amazing
throughout that that light festival that
took place in late November and in terms
of the other bit of news it was a
pleasure to attend our annual time to
shine Awards and recognize our amazing
Council offices and teams that was a
lovely event a couple of weeks ago that
I know some colleagues across different
parties were able to join us at however
finally I would like to say a few words
on the current situation in Gaza and
Israel and the effect that it's having
here in traford right now as you'll all
be aware there are people protesting
protesting outside the town hall it's
their right to protest we are a proudly
de Democratic country and we stand up
for people's
rights since October we have been filled
with horror and despair at the growing
conflict in the Middle East Trafford is
a burough of thousands of miles away but
we are still
connected there is a deep impact felt
within our communities and one of our
roles as a council is to help keep all
our communities safe and to feel safe it
is fair to say I've not said much
publicly on the situation aside from a
statement I made with the greater
Manchester mayor Deputy Mayor and nine
other Council leaders back in
October I feel that when passions are
enraged it's better to pause and reflect
rather than react and potentially cause
further outrage but do not mistake this
for inaction over the past few months
the chief executive and I have met with
faith leaders and listened to their
concerns for their communities that
includes the chair and chief officer of
the Jewish representative C Council
imams and leaders from Old Trafford
rabbis for from ultman Hal barns
trustees from the ultran ha Muslim
Association I have also met with other
Civic leaders and listened to their
opinions I have also heard the protests
that have taken place in Trafford
leadership is often about listening and
at this stage I would like to thank
individual members from across different
parties that helped facilitate those
meetings with key faith leaders from
from either each
Community I also attended a silent video
for peace at the at in Ultram at the
invitation of the local Interfaith group
The Silence was profound in that
powerful space void of words we found a
commonality we mourned the loss of
Innocent Lies We remembered that we are
more connected than divided we were
United in our prayers for
peace when each of the members here was
elected whatever our party we all
pledged to represent all people people
in our WS irrespective of party
Allegiance race age gender sexuality our
corporate Vision says Trafford is a
bough where all residents and businesses
and communities can prosper the key word
there is
all in all the discussions I've had with
faith leaders there has been a consensus
that the key to moving forward
positively is for us to continue to come
together to maintain dialogue to further
develop our respect and understanding
for each other and trafford's
communities and through this Foster
cohesion in our Borough our communities
can live together in peace and without
fear the best thing we can do is be an
example let others imitate our ability
to work together for the common good I
will not pretend that will there will
never be conflict but where there is a
difference we can be amicable without
the need of Frets or
violence when the time is right we can
demonstrate Community cohesion in action
by bringing all faiths together at the
town hall for a vigil in the spirit of
unity we can come together and show we
are stronger when we stand
together already in healthare in Social
care in education we see Community
cohesion every day Jewish and Muslim
brothers and sisters work along each
other for the common good so let us
follow their example and be an example
for all of us to follow follow and I'll
end on that thank you
mayor thank you leader there's the chair
of scrutiny commit scrutiny committees
have anything to announce on behalf of
their committee I can ask you to limit
your announcements to one minute each
please councilor
Acton thank you mayor um I'll I'll be
shorter than that
uh obviously tonight we've got a a heavy
agenda so um I just wanted members to
know that uh i i attended executive on
Monday evening where I presented two uh
reports um from scrutiny and um one of
those was uh the task and finish group
scrutiny regarding the impact of ma
match and event days have been on the
local uh Community the residents and
businesses and people who work around
the ground and because are many issues
and problems and and um I'm pleased to
say that we managed to uh put a report
together from
scrutiny um and I think that um the
leader said quite clearly that uh you
know he'll look at the
recommendations um and uh try to
implement some of them the other report
was a scrutiny response uh to to the
executive draft um plans and uh budget
plans um and I think um all members uh
are able to access both reports online
and I'd just like to say thanks to
councel David act me me members of
scrutiny uh for all the work that
they've done and the executive and uh
the officers who actually thank you coun
process thank
you councelor B
thank you Madame mayor uh we also had
our scrutiny meeting Health scrutiny and
we discussed at length some of the the
projects that were in place at the
moment where we had one on the blue
badge service got an update to see how
it's uh uh being assessed and uh
responded to by uh residents and you
know some of the stats behind it we also
looked at the preparations that are
going on for the
CQC um adult social care side of things
uh and feeding into
that also uh we had a the integrated
care partnership update on that as well
so on the whole there's a lot of work
going on and uh we're feeding into those
various uh bodies to try and help the uh
residents of Trafford so we'll continue
on that and I'll give you a further
update which I gave it a comprehensive
update on the execs but keep you updated
on the next one thank
you councelor Denise
Weston nothing at this point Thank You
chair uh item three is
questions item three questions and
members have submitted 10 questions for
this meeting which have been listed on
the council website for members of the
public to
view on the basis that I've asked for
the responses to be circulated to all
counselors and published on the website
I will take both the question and
responses read and move on to the
supplementary question in each case
where a response is not yet been
provided I will invite the executive
member to respond this
evening the first question is from
councelor
chakrabarti councelor chakrabati has had
a response to his question concerning
the Pelican Crossing at the junction of
sindland Road and the
a56 therefore do you have a
supplementary question please councelor
Chaka thank you madam mayor um thanks
for the qu answer to the question which
is satisfactory at the moment an leld
aspiration of the residents of broad
heat has been to get a pelican Crossing
at the junction of a56 cinderland Road
and Salsbury road crossing which H has
been a significant danger to while
crossing per pedestrians Crossings so we
have a timeline and that's what we are
asking for can we be certain that it
will be completed by the summer when the
schools go go For Recess thank you thank
you
counselor do we have a response from the
executive thank you uh mayor and thank
you for your supplementary question CC
check back at this point I don't have a
full timeline for it but relay is with
myself and highways manager over the
coming period sure we can actually
Supply that information for you local
residents thank
you thank you
counselor question two and three sorry
question two and the first of two
questions from councelor Evans councelor
Evans has not had response to his
question regarding the child protection
can the executive member now response
please yeah thank you um mayor and thank
you Mr councelor Evans for raising this
really important issue um as you know
traff Council have worked hard during
the past four years to ensure that
children who are at risk of sexual
exploitation are safeguarded
effectively following the 2019
inspection of children's services an
improvement notice was put in place
which in included an independently
chaired board we have an Ambitions plan
and one of the outcomes of that plan was
to to establish a vulnerable adolescent
service a significant investment took
place with the introduction of the new
team called
shine um and that was established to
work intensively to prevent and protect
children and young people who were at
risk or who have experienced child
exploitation I can send you the rest of
the response but in answer to your
specific
query um GMP currently have two
investigations ongoing one one is a non
recent investigation with three victims
and a suspect and the file is currently
with the CPS awaiting a decision from
them the second is a non recent
investigation with three victims and two
suspects this is reop a reopened
investigation which is also ongoing and
the file will be submitted to the CPS
after the final interview next week and
the third investigation has recently
been closed after the suspect was
charged with several drug related
offenses so we have no current csse
investigations going on with any
children in
traford thank you
counselor um do do you have a
supplementary question counc Evans thank
you thank thank you thank you Madame May
thank you to the executive member for
the comprehensive answer it is a
worrying time um have I would ask and I
appreciate that answer have we done a
thorough look back this goes back within
GM Beyond four years this goes back 20
years and to all administrations and
it's not really about the
administrations it's about gmp's
response Etc have we gone back that far
have we asked GMP GMP yes we're we're
now at the fourth we're now on the
fourth inquiry so the first two um
focused I hope I'm right on this focused
on historic sexual abuse and then the
the third one has been specifically
around what happened in Rochdale and the
fourth part which is just commencing now
um overseen by Kate green the PPC is
about ensuring that all services are
working together to do to hope that to
try and prevent it is where we're at we
don't know how long stage 4 is going to
take it's just started because obviously
we've just had the rdale um report but
um all I can say is there a great will
that nothing like that will ever happen
again thank you
counselor councelor dunan question three
as a response for his question regarding
the drug abuse in schools and can I ask
councelor Duncan if he has a
supplementary question
please yeah hi thank you Madame yes I
do okay so again thank you very much for
the informative um reply I do know that
the teams um do work hard so again thank
you for your
response in your
reply you confirm the council are now in
the process of developing a joint
strategic assessment relating to the
increase with drug and alcohol intake
with our young
people could I ask the council Pleasers
to WR just
now and does this mean you are in the
process of now recruiting in order to
better understand the unmet needs for TR
uh for traveled young people so
therefore could I ask how long it will
take to gather this information in order
to gain better understanding one month
two months three months or six months
thank you uh counsel councelor Duncan I
was surprised you asked this question
because you sat through the presentation
that lasted over an hour in Children's
School scrutiny last week where um there
was plenty of opportunity to ask these
questions um I'm afraid I don't know how
long um obviously you heard from the
early break team that they have a good
understanding they talked to us about
the rise of children taking camine and
um you know I'm looking at Council
Weston here they did they talked about
the unmet need for quite a lot of that
presentation so um I but I don't know I
know we have just started the jsna
process I don't know how long it will
take and I will get the answer back to
you thank you councilor Carter question
four is a question from councelor Paul
Council Paul has asked a response to a
question about the council buying new
camp by the buy new campaign do you have
a supplementary question Council of PA
please uh thank you madam mayor uh thank
you for the answer I have reviewed it
and I do have a supplementary question
uh saying this has a small effect on the
retail sector assumes that the retail
sector in Trafford is in good position
which we know it isn't as the retail
sector in Trafford is suffering will the
council support a buy everything local
campaign to support our local shops and
businesses thank
you Council can you
respond thank you uh May and Council
propo for your supplementary question
I'm sure the council could support all
sorts of initiatives like that there a
lot around uh obviously the the purpose
of the uh not bu anything new in January
is because of the farway society that we
have and then it instead of buying
something new you might want to go to a
charity shop or one of our reu shops and
buy something so it's still in the local
economy you're still putting money into
the local there but it's not necessarily
buying something new the amount of waste
particularly things like textiles
worldwise is enormous and not
sustainable and we cannot carry on with
sort of wastage my electrical and other
products I'm not sure where you're qu
you're putting your original question
about pet because obvious that isn't
simply in the equation so I don't know I
have no answer to that one there
particularly but is I think perhaps what
we could do is find if members need it
some training about the circular economy
that we need to move to to ensure that
Society is working as a whole and it's
not just simply anymore about recycling
it's about repurposing and actually
reusing products so recycling should be
seen has much lower option than it has
been in the past so we're happy to
support all such initiatives that
actually benefit local
communities thank
you thank you counselor question five is
from councel Coggins Council cogin has
not had a response from her question
about the
council's commemorative policy can I ex
can I ask the executive member now to
response please and I think that's
councelor
Hines thank you um May and can I
respectfully request that I remain
seated um just for purposes of eyesight
so I can read the response many thanks
um May um so I would like to thank
councelor Coggins for this question it
is an important question um and there
have been several queries in respect of
this position and policy and I think it
is important for me to set out some
background and information which will
hopefully provide you with some
assurances as to the appropriateness of
the policy creation the subsequent
implementation
and also the unusual circumstances in
respect of this particular
petition previously the council operated
a flag flying
policy however this policy had narrow
application and also did not cover other
commemorative activities undertaken by
the
council this meant that when requests
were received by the council for a
particular activity the policy wasn't
always helped ful in guiding the
decision- making process the flag flying
policy was subject to an annual review
to determine and agree events for which
flags would be flown in the upcoming
year in early November internal
discussions commenced between Council
officers the leader of the council and
myself as Deputy leader with
responsibility for the flag flying
policy about the annual review and the
policy Fitness for purpose
the review came as we reflected on a
number of requests that had been
received and I will return to this
further in my
response several areas of the policy
were identified as needing Improvement
including that the policy did not cover
the situation where new flags and events
were introduced it did not cover
lighting up of buildings and no policy
did and it did not cover remembrance
Sunday and no policy did General
consensus was that it could be improved
in the following ways scope expanding to
cover other commemorative
activities categories of flags to be
flown um to be reviewed and the
council's position in respect of
lighting gut buildings to be
confirmed on this basis it was agreed
that a commemorative policy would be
developed and I think it's important at
this stage for me to set out the
timelines and activities
involved the consideration of the policy
was ongoing throughout November last
year with a new draft being circulated
in early December for review and
comments the commemorative policy
2024 was developed in consultation with
the corporate leadership team the chief
executive the leader of the council and
me a final draft was produced on the
15th of December for review and final
discussion by the chief exac the leader
and me there was an agreement in
principle on the content subject to the
to the completion of the formal approval
process in this instance the relevant
executive member and the decision maker
was me as I have executive responsib
ibility for the policy which Falls
within my portfolio and as such I have
delegated authority within the council's
Constitution to consider and approve
policies which relate to my
portfolio the final policy draft was
sent to me on the 1st of January
2024 approval was confirmed by me on the
5th of January
2024 the decision notice was published
on the 15th of January and the calling
period applied which meant the decision
was subject to a 5-day calling period as
the decision has not been called in it
is now effective and within the context
of the question I've had this evening
it's important for me to stress that
there was a decision in principle to
approve the policy made on the 15th of
December the Democratic team received
the petition on the 28 8 of December but
this was not acknowledged until the 2nd
of January due to the holiday period the
petition was received after the decision
in principle had already been made the
formal decision was made on the 5th of
January however following a request to
light up the building the petitioner was
informed by the leader of the Council on
the 1st of December that the policy was
already under review there was a
conscious decision not to delay the
policy decision to hear the petition due
to the concerns and considerations that
I will now
explain in the development and
subsequent approval of the commemorative
policy the following factors were
reflected
on the current conflicts in Gaza and
Israel Reflections on the potential for
tension and conflict in our communities
arising from from flag flying and the
lighting up of
buildings the potential impact of of
this on our own elected members and
Council officers on safety and
well-being the impact on residents on
our communities and on
cohesion in addition to this we
reflected on the high number of requests
for for flags and the lighting up of
buildings the required resource to make
uh to manage those requests and action a
vast array of different requests which
meant it was not possible or sustainable
to accept them
all a reflection on the conflicting
requests that we were receiving and the
arising issues and on the difficulties
of maintaining a fair consistent
approach to dealing with those requests
and the potential for the minimization
of the impact when it was too regularly
used we also reflected on the financial
costs within the context of the
council's current budgetary constraints
the significant costs of lighting up
buildings the cost of purchasing and
maintaining different
flags these factors were also considered
in determining the appropriateness of
the petition as was the fact that the
policy had been under review since
November the leader had also been
talking as he spoken about this evening
with faith leaders and had already
notified the petitioner in December that
the policy was under review after our
Reflections on recent
requests the fact that the decision
regarding the new commemorative policy
had already been taken in principle
before the petition had been received
was also considered the council's
commemorative policy is clear and it's
based on a rational which is intended to
avoid any action which could con cause
conflict or tension this particular
conflict has had profound and
far-reaching
consequences on our communities our
staff and our elected members and in
recognition of the unusual circumstances
a decision was made not to accept the
petition whilst the Constitution does
not provide a specific pres provision in
respect of the council's ability to not
accept a petition a logical and
pragmatic approach was taken to exercise
discretion in exceptional circumstances
based on risk and significant concerns
the decision was not taken lightly and
was taken by the director of legal and
governance in consultation with the
chief exek the leader of the council and
myself as Deputy leader of the council
and in relation to the question about
the Ukrainian flag um my understanding
was that there was a short delay between
the request for the flag to be taken
down and Facilities actioning that
request but the flag has now been taken
down thank
you thank you councelor Hines do you
have a supplementary question councelor
cogins I do yes thank you councelor
Hines for your reply um uh for the
detailed reply and to um yes does the
council understand that the
unnecessarily Hasty nature of this
decision has given an impression and
this is words have come to me from a
number of different people of double
standards um and that maybe a short
delay to the implementation of this
policy would have to use councelor
hines's words been a more fair and
consistent response to the human
humanitarian disaster we're witnessing
in Gaza and to its impacts on our local
communities here thank you
thank you question six is the second
question from sorry oh sorry I
need sorry Council H who respond to that
thank you oh thank you very much um I am
hoping that I have managed to set out
this evening um that there was no Hasty
response there was a reflection going
back actually um to November having
received requests and some of the um
some of the challenges and difficulties
and concerns that were raised at that
time and the fact that our policy itself
did not cover these eventualities so
that decision making process itself at
the time that we received um previous
requests wasn't where we needed it to be
um hence why we began that um review um
and that formulation of that policy
and and councelor Ross as the leader of
the council had spoken to the petitioner
back in December in order to make sure
that people were aware actually that the
policy was under review to avoid such
circumstances where people might
perceive it that there was an imbalance
and an inconsistency Council Ross has
continued to have those
conversations um with faith Leaders with
the community it is fundamentally
important to this Administration to this
Council that we do that that we make
maintain that Community cohesion um that
is the purpose of the policy um the
reason it's been implemented at that
time is for all those reasons that I do
hope will be taken in the spirit in
which it is intended actually to to
Foster and promote that Community
cohesion um and if it hasn't been taken
in that way um then I hope um it will be
after this explanation this evening
thank you thank you councelor
Hines question six this is the second of
the two questions from councilman Evans
councelor Evans has had a response to
his question about a school provision in
Trafford and can the executive member
Now respond please councilor Carter yes
um I'm going to start by saying I don't
like this question I don't like the tone
I don't like the
wording I went to um our legal and
Democratic officer and she said that
questions are there to encourage
political debate and
discussion so that's what we'll
do how dare you say that the future
labor government is a threat and you use
that word
twice I'm going to tell you about the
reality of people living under this Tory
government there are currently 14.4
million people living in poverty
including four 4.2 children and 2.1
million
pensioners a record number of people are
waiting to see the GP and the have a
Hospital
appointment the reality is a trussle
trust gave out over 3 million food
Parcels last year the reality is that
there is sewage in our rivers and seas
we currently have the highest ever
number of people who are homeless and
rough sleeping renters rights have been
curtailed and people are living in damp
moldy
houses the reality is that under the
tor's watch we've seen scandals
involving the post office crul wind
Windrush contaminated
blood after the disastrous trust Quang
budget millions of people are paying
more for their mortgages and this week a
government Minister resigned because he
couldn't afford to pay his on a salary
of
118,000 I can't forget the day that
people partied in the garden in Downing
Street in lockdown the day that we
buried my father-in-law who died of
covid in a care
home so that's when we when you talk
about a threat I look at the reality of
what we're all suffering under this
government and the whole country knows
it's time for
change so you want to talk about a
future policy in a government that
hasn't been elected yet there was a poll
this weekend in the times and the time
said that said the policy to charge VAT
on Independent Schools is strongly
supported by every possible demographic
young old male female apart from people
who went to private schools or send
their children to one so no I haven't
visited any Independent Schools to
discuss this issue and I've got no
intention of doing
so I stand shoulder to- shoulder with
Bridget pH phipson on this policy and if
parents can't afford the fees then these
children will be warmly welcomed into
the state
sector I detail the schools that have
got vacancies at exec on Monday night
and I would imagine virtually everyone
in this chamber has either attended a
Trafford School sent their children to a
Trafford school or govern in a Trafford
school so we can all testify to what an
excellent system we have children will
receive a great education
and parents will save a Fortune winner
winner School dinner is what I
say thank
[Applause]
you do you have a supplementary question
Council ens
please thank thank you Madame May the
reality is we have local parents
struggling to send their children
children to school not confident in the
provision that you are
providing they may be forced out of
these schools and these schools will
suffer a loss of 15 to 20% of their
clients who want to better phrase
children they will end up in our
Trafford schools which you know will not
be able to absorb up to
450 children you simply know that so why
are you not even
considering that as a threat which it
clearly is to both the current State
education system and the private sector
and our residents it is a threat you
should be considering it if you are not
you are sorely lacking in your
responsibilities there you've absolutely
just made that figure
up how have you any idea that there are
450 parents who are thinking that they
might not be able to afford to send
their children schools you don't know
because we don't know we were genuinely
concerned when Loretto prep wasn't
sustainable and we had lots of
discussions about which schools would be
able to take those children in the end
we didn't need to those parents went and
found other Independent Schools we did
not have that influx that we imagined we
would have so obviously we think about
these things you already know on Monday
night said about we're getting 300 extra
places at alterum College of Arts we've
got places in Broad Oak and in lostock
and wellacre if children want to come
into the state system we would more than
welcome them and and I cannot for one
minute start going around Independent
Schools going woe is me the government
hasn't been elected yet this policy
hasn't been introduced and if it is
introduced there's every likelihood it's
going to be done incrementally so it's
just a ridiculous thing
and and if if it happens then if PRI
Independent Schools want to discuss it
with the authority we'll be more than
welcome to do so but we're not just
going to imagine things are going to
happen with the threat of a labor
government thank you councelor Madame
mayor there was a question at the start
of that response am I allowed to respond
to that sorry no
sorry question seven is a question from
counc Spencer councelor Spencer has not
had a response to our question about the
endangered M monkeys and can the
executive member Now respond
please thank you thank you for the
question the Imports of live animals
into the UK are regulated by the animal
and plant health agency which is part of
defra local authorities have no
regulatory invol involvement in this
process any Imports of live animals has
to be notified to the animal and plant
health authority using the Imports of
products animals food and Fe feed
systems I pass for short the Importer
must send notification at least one
working day before the consignment is
due to arrive in the UK to the iass
system the animal and plant health
agency will will carry out carry and
identify and pH and do physical checks
on Imports of live animals at their
destination based on biocurity and
public health risks the council is
current currently seeking further detail
on the numbers and species of animals
imported into Manchester Airport if
there are any at all and we will provide
counselor Spencer an update once we' H
once that's
available thank you
counselor councelor Spencer do you have
a supplementary question thank you yes I
do thank you thank you for your response
um I just wondered if you could clarify
what the council's position is as a key
stakeholder at Manchester Airport on
this activity um especially in light of
the fact that these monkeys were
officially classed as endangered back in
2022 thank
you councelor Thompson can you pray
please thank you for that uh obviously
that's a much wider question um
we are reassured by the airport by the
airport group that they operate within
the law and indeed it would be
inappropriate for the airport to start
acting independently of the law the
focus of the labor policy and the rspca
is to press for viable alternatives to
animal testing Banning the importation
of animals from Manchester Airport if
there are any AO avoids the substantive
e ethical issue of how to balance the
desire to treat human illnesses and
maintain the welfare of nonhuman
primates again the law supports the best
possible welfare conditions until viable
alternatives to animal testing are
developed thank you thank you
counselor question eight is from
councilor Z Council Z has had response
to his question about the oneway system
on gorsy Lane do you have a
supplementary question counc Z
please uh thank you Madame mayor the
response highlighted that after six-
month period there will be there will be
an assessment of the effectiveness of
this one-way system on go Lane could you
please provide a detail a detailed
explanation of the criteria that must be
met in order to reverse this oneway
system on
go thank you could councel respond
please
thank you mayor and thank you councelor
for your supplementary question as
outlined in the original response to you
is there's a maximum period of 18 months
and the first six months will be for
review during that time yourself and
other residents can actually submit
concerns discuss with officers and at
the end of that six months if any of
those subst substantiated or indeed that
there are ways in which things can be
altered and and then there's a further
12 month in which to actually implement
given the total of 18 months so
obviously do lay with the officers you
have been Ling with over recent periods
obviously that's we're now into this
6mon period so please use that and your
residence and actually take the time to
actually engage on it uh obviously I
don't think necessarily that the council
chamber is a correct place to having
these sort of discussion because they
simply yes no uh type questions you need
to be sitting down with officers and
discussing these if you got concerns and
your vant need to discussing them on a
on front of a table on front of a
virtual meeting uh because we can't be
address those concerns here in this sort
of situation Council CH be but that the
door is open there and you have six
months in which to actually discuss any
concerns that you have on behalf of the
residents thank
you thank you councelor question nine is
a question from Council laori Council
laori has had a response to his question
about brsk infrastructure roll out do
you have a supplementary question
councelor
pory I do mayor thank you very much um
and thank you for the answer um many
residents have raised the lack of
information notice given uh often waking
up to a new poll outside the house um
Can the council commit to monitoring
brsk communication uh methods and make
sure they do all they can to inform
residents more effectively ahead of
planned
works thank
you thank you uh councelor for your
supplementary question as you may be
aware the conservative government gave
these companies not just be SK but
several other companies as well poers to
basically do all these things that they
are doing now do not have to inform with
the local Force they nearly not notify
that of their intention a period before
which they do it we have no powers to
intervene with it unless they are doing
things like causing an obstruction or
the like which uh they have been going
around the B over the last couple years
they've been in my world somewhere
before last and and on a small number of
occasions we did have some interventions
where they were clearly caused an
obstruction but aside of we have no
powers to intervene on this so I'm aware
obviously that conservative back Ben
ches did raises with government and and
there's quite a standoff of believe
we've G on that one there but obviously
I'm not aware that any changes have been
made to legislation so in that fact we
have no powers or to intervene in these
type matters Unfortunately they simply
bypass local fs and it's a concern
through the whole country in which the
way these measures have actually been
troduced but it's beyond do that sense
to it but obviously if if yourself do
have low concerns say things like an
obstructions those sorts of things then
obviously do speak with us and highways
officers and and those concerns can be
justified we can actually look at leing
with those companies and see if we can
get it moved in those circumstances
thank you thank you
councelor question 10 this is the last
of tonight's questions and is from
councelor noos councelor noos has not
had a response to his question about the
Takeover of traffic Housing Trust from
London quadrant can the executive member
Now respond please
uh yeah thank you mayor and thank you
councel and you asked for your question
uh I fully appreciate your concern
regarding the lack of public access to
sale points I am too disappointed this
access has been removed and I'll share
your concerns regarding the lack of
local presence being easy accessible to
Residents I have had a response from Len
Q in relation to this which I will uh
Now read out when a query comes in if
this cannot be resolved on the phone or
remotely we then ensure the right person
or persons are sent to where they are
needed is requested by the customer this
is generally a home visit but especially
if the quer query is of a sensitive
nature leading to the customer feeling
uncomfortable discussing at their own
home it could be take place in a
community center family members home
Limelight Etc we also offer face-to-face
appointments at sale Point utilizing the
meeting rooms on the ground floor the
decision to close the reception was down
to two main reasons firstly the very low
numbers of customers accessing the
service which in the period it was
reopened never exceeded 10 in a day and
was often much lower secondly due to
staff being out in neighborhoods and
visiting customers there are often not
the right people in the office to deal
with a query meaning the customer then
made an appointment or we contacted them
by phone extending the time it took to
resolve
queries the low number of customers
accessing the reception service and the
ability to deal with queries in the
moment me the service was not deem value
for money and the staff members who
service reception could help increase
numbers of customers more effective L as
part of the wider customer offer
outlined
above having said that I have met with
the chief executive officer Fiona
Fletcher Smith this year to reely my
concerns about a number of issues when I
regularly meet and have dialogue with
Allison H Partnerships director these
meetings are productive and L largely
reassuring however we do need to see
some progress on a number of issues
raised including local Services
maintenance of properties and others and
I will continue to press for this it is
worth pointing out however that traffic
Council have very few if any powers to
force any registered provider to have a
publicly accessible office whilst we
have some Powers around Property
Standards lettings and antisocial
Behavior we do not have any regulatory
Powers this sector is of course
regulated by the regulator of social
housing within the department of
leveling up I would welcome further
regulation in this sector as I'm sure
the majority of us would in this chamber
however this would take well from
government in order to happen and given
the incompetence and Chaos currently
ongoing in said government I see no real
progress being made on this matter for
some time if there is anything specific
that you would like me to raise with L
and Q either now or in the future I more
than happy for you to email me your
concerns thank you
ma'am thank you councelor Wright do you
have a supplementary question Council
noos yes um Mrs mayor can I thank you
for that extensive um answer um very
comprehensive um can I just ask uh so
under Trafford Housing Trust the leader
uh of our Council had a seat on the
board um that position of influence was
given away as a result of the lnq
Takeover of tht a fact that seemed to
surprise a lot of Labor councilors when
we raised it in scrutiny last year now
this Council has no seat at the table so
I'm interested in the executive member's
view given the less than Stellar
reputation of lnq given the fact that
they've already rolled back on promises
to our residents over access and given
that the ad Administration now has no
seat on the board do you agree with me
that this council is less able to stand
up for social housing tenants than it
was before the lnq
Takeover thank you thank you councelor
NEOS for your question I don't think
there's any doubt that we have less
influence on um lmq uh than we did on
the previous organization Trafford
Housing Trust uh yes I do have concerns
um and there are a number of issues that
I am working to get resolved along with
the rest of the executive and we will
continue to do that um I would very much
go back to what I said about the
regulator of social housing however
which is an important point because we
are limited to a certain degree as to
what we can do locally and I would very
much welcome some further legislation
and regulation brought in uh to further
protect social housing tant the one
thing I would say is that we are
currently looking to put something in
the diary forward an engagement session
with lnq and local counselors um across
across the Spectrum um within the next
few weeks or months hopefully before uh
the new Financial year comes around
thank
you thank you
councelor item four is membership of
committees item four is to advise the
council about the changes to one of the
council's substitutes on the greater man
of combined notor scrutiny committee
which is d detailed on the
summons is this this is for information
and can it be noted
please thank
you item five is review of polling
districts and polling places item five
is on the polling district and places
review and there has been plenty of
consultation on this matter the proposer
all speakers will be afforded 2 minutes
and I invite the executive member F
Finance change and governance to
introduce the report and move the
recommendations councilor Hardy please
thank you mayor um the report sets out
the proposals to enable the council to
comply with its statutary duty to review
all parliamentary polling districts and
polling places and to review all local
government polling districts and polling
places at the same time the
recommendations of the report are to
note the outcome of the review and
agreed the proposed locations uh there
are several appendix attached to the
report um there is an amendment that I
just want to make um people aware of the
proposed polling station in timly
central has changed to broomwood
Community Center we were initially
advised that the community center was
unavailable in May but they have now
offered us a room to
use this is the polling station we
normally use so there is no longer a
recommendation to use the 145 altringham
and hail Royal Air Cadet building as a
replacement the proposed polling station
in Brooklyn's has changed to the Mobile
station The Proposal was to use 318
sales Squadron Air Cadet building
however it is no longer available so we
will revert back to using the Mobile
station as we have done previously the
mayor outlined that there has been lots
of consultation on this report um we
have carried out engagement with members
numerous times emailed all members
regarding the review conducted dropping
sessions to discuss the proposals 11th
and 12th of December and held briefing
sessions to consult members on the
recommendations um so the report is
there thank you
mayor thank you councelor is that second
please and you're limited to two minutes
thank you so seconded May and I'll
reserve the
rights does any members wish to speak on
this
report thank you councelor Patel thank
you mayor um myself and my ward
colleagues um councilor basille and
Bennett um engaged with a consultation
on on on this uh polling Station review
and we'd like to thank officers for
their support during that process s
Moore has the fewest polling stations in
the burough it's served by three polling
stations one of one of which is actually
sits outside the ward and we're left
with a double-sized ward SM B3 um which
serves the um lnq housing estate which
has no polling station with it within it
obviously we've discussed this with
officers and we understand the reasons
why but whilst we accept the report and
the recommendations we would like get
noted that we would like to continue to
work with officers to find a solution um
to that situation and provide that Ward
uh with its own polling station within a
decent walking distance thank you thank
you councelor councelor
Welton thank you mayor um yeah I just
want to say thank you very much for all
the work that's gone into this I'll
declare an interest as a board member of
timley sports club which is becoming a
polling station um the club staff say
they hope people will enjoy visiting the
club and perhaps may wish to take
advantage of the excellent bar offering
there while they're there we we also
appreciate the move from Stanford
primary to hail Methodist Church uh
which means no more disruption at the
school and improved accessibility due to
the level access at hail Methodist thank
you thank you
counselor the report has
been sorry the report has been moved in
seconded and can it be agreed
please thank
you item six is six-month corporate
Report on health safety and well-being
from the 1st of April to the 30th of
September
2023 item six is the six- mon corporate
health and again all speakers will be
afforded two minutes and I invite the
deputy leader of the council and
executive member for leisure arts
culture and Heritage to introduce the
report thank you thank you mayor um I
will be brief because members will have
had the report and no doubt read the
report um and it is for noting but just
to draw out some key highlights actually
before I do that I would like to thank
the officers um and uh Simon Whitehead
in particular um for this report but
just to draw out a couple of the
highlights from the report um you will
note really that the report provides key
health and safety performance
information and activities undertaken by
the health and safety unit working with
Partners it outlines initiatives still
delivered with Partners to support our
Workforce under the Epic your health and
well-being strategy um it does highlight
the proactive um audits that are taking
place and the support um that's been
implemented so there's been um a
libraries audit um which happened during
April to September 2023 and that was of
the North Area libraries they were
audited on a range of health and safety
and management issues um and a
comprehensive report was provided um
which gave an overarching summary of
performance across the north Library
Service as a whole um and a supportive
action plan um to improve the health and
safety Arrangements was also put into
place the South area libraries um will
be completed um soon they'll they'll be
carrying out the same process um there's
also been supported living um themed
interventions uh and the services
received of variety of support to
develop safety and well-being
arrangements for staff and service users
um and the health and safety unit
continues to assist the one Trafford
client team in monitoring the health and
safety performance of Amy delivering our
contracted Services um in terms of
schools support there is a comprehensive
service level agreement delivered to our
schools with 80 schools having purchased
the latest agreement
um and uh there is a collaborative
delivery of a range of health and
well-being activities which are detailed
in the report um and the opportunities
that are available to the
workforce um thank you councelor Hines
can you sorry what was that please is
that is that okay now yep I will I'll
leave it be at that point then thank
you thank you is that seconded please
seconded mayor and I'll reserve the
right thank
you do any me Members wish to speak on
this report
please councilor
pory thank you mayor and thank you for
the report and um we welcome this report
and this is merely just uh clarification
because of my background I'm used to
having your ridor scale one two you know
from minor up to to
severe which is in here but I think
you've got the severe in there and then
everything else is bunched to together
and and I'm assuming it is somewhere
where we've got it all scaled so we can
actually look at those level one
incidents how we going to reduce them to
nothing level two how we're going to
reduce them and the action plans around
those three different levels before you
get to severe and that was my question
it was just can we have that in future
uh reports because I think it would be
good to see the severity risks across
all the areas as well thank you yeah I
think that should
thank
you councelor Welton
please thank you um and thank you for
the work that's gone into this report um
while we take on board the work being
done to encourage reporting we must all
be concerned by the number of incidence
of violence and aggression that are
recorded in the report I'm sure the the
green group would like um like and
everyone in the chamber I'm sure would
like to record our thanks to all our
public facing staff particular our
teachers and School staff our home to
school transport staff and our customer
services team who put themselves at risk
every day uh to help our community thank
you thank you councelor councelor boort
please thank you Madame mayor uh I just
wanted to make a point about uh table
four uh 2.2.4 through Community Schools
by audit type uh and scores uh I was
just wondering is it possible to have a
bit more detail behind the headline sort
of figures in the form of some kind of
rug report so that showing graphically
uh uh over three years year before or
year after so that uh you see what the
trend is uh how it's changing um also
show how the health and safety unit is
sort effective how effective it is just
thought I'd make that point if if
possible thank you counselor the
reporter is for information and can be
noted
please item seven is motions this
evening we have three motions and have
been listed on the Summits in order that
they were received I don't expect to
limit speeches at this stage but may
have to do so depending on the time so
can I ask you please to keep your
speeches concise and to provide
repetition thank
you motion
7A proceeding with this with motion the
first m motion concerning the debate not
hate I have received notice that
councilor Evans is to move
please thank you m madame mayor and as
first up may I uh take this opportunity
to associate myself with councelor
Ross's comments uh regarding Tony Lloyd
um I'd our group like to pay respects to
Tony um and although I only knew of him
and didn't actually know him many of my
older colleagues uh over the past couple
of weeks have approached me and and the
comments are good guy Jon and MP and
actually from across the chamber I think
that that that says a lot so our
considerations with Judith whatever she
is uh from our from our group and also
the wider colleagues with it within our
our party so thank you thank you for
that opportunity Madame May um and then
tur to the motion again thank you Madame
mayor and thank you to this chamber uh
for receiving this motion um we all
enter politics for our own reasons H and
everyone in this chamber will have their
own personal experience experiences that
caused them to step up and stand for
office uh it may not surprise you to
guess that in my case it was a principal
stance taken by our own MP in Alman s
West who at the time stepped away from
being a member of The Shadow cabinet
when our own party took the contrary
decision on his position on education my
feeling was and remains one of
admirations for his stance and I felt
compelled to assist whenever and
wherever I could I had no inclin that it
would lead to me standing here on a
monthly basis advocating for my beliefs
and the beliefs of my residents
obviously over time and individuals
reasons for being involved and
continuing to be involved in political
life evolves I walk out on my streets
and see things that should and could be
improved and engage further that may be
as simple as trimming trees reporting
pootles and assisting businesses with
covid grants as many of us in here did
but I could never have imagined the
level of abuse ridicule that is directed
at elected officials for Simply Having a
a different world view and I know that I
get off lightly um others suffer much
worse simply for advocating for our
residents some of my and our colleagues
have been subject to abuse of sexist
homophobic racial abuse just for
advocating valid views and I'm sure
there are members within this chamber
who have received worse treatment for
having a different view I'll take a very
simple really simple simple example from
within this Council we had a proposal
this month for a strategy for walking
and cying and within that proposal were
ideas some of which I thought were
tenuous at best but were very harmful to
some of our residents I'm sure there are
members here who thought all the
proposals didn't go far enough just one
example but it highlights two World
Views neither of them in themselves
wrong wrong just two views and both
views worthy of respect what we all know
any debate around these emotive issues
will rapidly descend to an uncomfortable
place rather than debate regularly
ending in
abuse sadly this descend into abuse
intimidation and ridicule isn't reserved
for social media it does seep into wider
life and even this chamber it'll be
interesting to see following this motion
which I urge the whole chamber support
because it's brought in good faith how
the coming debates are addressed by
members across the chamber it's crucial
as we need more people involved in our
Chambers and nationally but regularly we
hear of friends retiring early not
because they have achieved their goals
within politics but because of bullying
and
intimidation I will re reference one
section from the
motion if left to continue this negative
and unacceptable Behavior can prevent
elected members from from representing
the communities they serve deter
individuals from standing for election
and undermine local democracy how can
anybody argue with that statement unless
their aim is to actually exclude certain
views um that they deem unacceptable so
I urge all members to support this
motion uh and to the when do we address
the Amendments do you want it now or do
you want it
then thanks counselor um thank you is
this motion seconded
please uh yes uh thank you madam mayor
uh I would like to second the motion
supporting healthy debate and against
hateful toxic abuse in local politics it
is very difficult for many minority
groups to feel enable to get involved in
politics at any level as a local
counselor I know that I have experienced
abuse and unfortunately abuse of a
racial
nature women in politics in particular
face an extraordinarily harsh toxic and
misogynistic political environment which
targets them in a gendered manner and it
does not Target men in the same way
people from all backgrounds should feel
able to participate in politics at any
level without having to face a toxic
abusive and hateful environment that
makes attacks based upon their minority
status it it is for these reasons that I
would like to Second this motion thank
you thank
you I have received two amendments to
this
motion I invite Council lorei to move
the First Amendment and you have two
minutes please thank
you thank you mayor and I would also
like to associate myself and my group
with the words of councelor Ross and
counselor Evans regarding um Tony Lloyd
I met him twice within the the past nine
years I don't need convinced about his
honesty and drive for Public Service uh
he was he was a lovely man and he'll be
deeply missed by all um now to our
Amendment um the liberal Democrat group
agrees with the local government
Association motion that's been set
forward however we believe some things
have been omitted which is why we're
bringing this
amendment I can go back and talk about a
time of your of when when politics was
seemed all honest and and we listened to
one another and and we debated honest
honestly they did kind of exist we were
all passionate we all spoke up but we
all came to
resolution of course rightly or wrongly
different political factions and parties
were Jered or cheered for their
beliefs manners and debate still
mattered and raising the bar of public
debate was expected of those in elected
office and those seeking it that has all
changed and in the past 20 years and
especially since
2016 the emergence of social media was
supposed to bring us all closer together
a vision stated by Mark Zuckerberg
himself however it has in fact divided
us more with its algorithms and targeted
popups allowing the farri right to
manipulate and Gaslight Nations across
the world with or without Russian bot
Farms giving birth to local trolls who
believe the rules don't apply to them we
have hopefully learned to mute these
accounts and move forward however some
haven't in fact the local conservative
group have actively engaged with these
people hidden behind their fake names
and cartoon profile pictures happily
reposting and liking content designed to
incite rather than inform don't worry
I've got the
screenshots the national conservative
party are not much better using print
media social media and now the
right-wing broadcast channel to shame
bully and stir the hatred and ignorance
pot moring common poll from August
September of last
year asked about trust in public
institutions and they listed them all
I'm not going to go through them all but
suffice to say the top 10 have all been
attacked by this conservative government
The National Trust The Honorable Jacob
Reese MOG The National Trust regrettably
dislikes our
nation
seriously the courts I think we can all
remember from a few years ago
enemies of the state on the front cover
of the Daily
Mail and the BBC the culture secretary
was on TV last week claiming bias do you
know what if I'm saying the BBC is
biased you're saying the BBC is biased
and the Tes is saying the BBC is biased
it's doing its job
properly this is not a single party
issue there have been plenty of examples
from across the political spectrum of
late but is this the way it is or a
reaction to extremist views we are
seeing from from the conservative party
and their allies in reform UK I
personally have been the victim of both
left and right over the years and have
learned to brush it off however it
should be called
out we should be able to call out
ignorance racism homophobia transphobia
anti-Semitism and islamophobia without
the social villainy we see from
right-wing endorsed individuals we
should be able to State evidence and
fact and not have it labeled as fake
news and we should expect our political
opponents to act like adults and not
obeying BMP ukip National front cover
band thank you very much please support
this amendment thank you
councelor is that seconded
please yes M mayor um so I was quite
surprised to see this motion come
forward from the conservative
group given the behaviors of the current
prime minister and the one before the
shortest serving one in British history
it seemed rather
hypocritical we are supportive of the
motion but we have
um we have an amendment which seeks to
clarify and understand how the actions
of individuals and organiz organizations
matter they use the platforms such like
s such as media and Parliament for
political gain and it whips up hatred
for marginalized groups of
individuals one such group are trans
women they've been they've been
basically their existence is mocked by
people hiding behind pseudo science I'm
happy to discuss this with anybody who
thinks they understand human genetics
better than me by at least two
conservative Prime Ministers just
because you don't understand something
or haven't experienced it it doesn't
mean that it isn't real mocking is not
debating is it it prays upon the lack of
understanding and singles out smaller
groups for being
different it Harbors hate it pits one
lot against another and it leads to the
rise of hate crimes that we have
seen it is indeed a privilege to be
elected to public office and it comes
with a responsibility for us all to
Foster Harmony in our community Not to
cause division thank
you thank you
counselor the first amendment has been
moved and seconded it and I invite
speakers inspected the first amendments
only please and you have two minutes
speakers thank
you councelor Evans
please thank you Madame mayor um liberal
Democrats sadly missing the point it
starts here if it doesn't start at the
bottom it's never going to reach the top
and it is about how we behave to each
other because this is about local
democracy this is a local government
Association campaign not in National
this is about local government fantastic
you managed to blame the right wing but
you could quite easily have blamed the
fbp group BLM social justice brexit if
you want to but actually it isn't about
division it's about debate it's about
understanding that other people have a
different view so to address your
Amendment which actually isn't as bad as
what you've actually said the second and
third paragraph are quite acceptable but
your thought that it started in 2016 or
with brexit or with 2019 is so missing
the point so I quite happily accept
2third of your Amendment and I would
urge you to remove the first paragraph
because actually we all should be
standing together in support of Motions
like this because it we will not have
people to stand here next year and the
year after and we all know how difficult
it is and I say that from us but I know
how difficult it is for you to get
candidates because it is tough to be
here so I urge you to remove your first
paragraph the sharp rise in hate speech
towards these public life since 2016 EX
ET quite happily accept your second two
it did not start in
2016 it did not start with rightwing
it's equally as bad with fvp but it is
not a national issue it's a local
government campaign if you want to keep
it like that so be it but we will not be
accepting it and urge everybody else to
take this Motion in the spirit that it
is offered frankly um and reject this
amendment please thank you councilor
Evans councelor Ross
please thank you may I won't talk for
too long um but we I just wanted to
clarify our position as a labor group in
terms of the Amendments and the Motions
this evening first of all um I really
appreciate and listen to all the
contributions both from councelor Evans
and from councelor leore and councelor
minis as well I think youve made some
very very good points in the things that
you said and the experiences people have
had both within this chamber in in a
wider political Arena around um the
level of debate and hate targeted at
people of all political colors as a
group I know that my colleagues will be
standing and speaking to this this this
this matter tonight because it's an
important matter but we've took a look
at each of the the motion and the two
amendments and as it stands we will not
be supporting the lib demo motion but if
we get to the green party motion we will
be supporting that I'll leave to that
thank you
mayor thank you councelor councelor FR
please thank you mayor whatsoever you
sow that you shall also reap if you sow
division in Parliament it's little
wonder when you go knocking on doors you
harvest anger if you plant wedges in
society it's little wonder that social
media is a field of hatred this whole
motion this debate this amendment
strikes at the very heart of what it is
to be a capital l liberal too many
liberals myself included assume that our
view of the balance between MPS and
individual rights democracy and and
councilors it's all obvious well
actually it's not many leaders turn to
populism the idea that the only valid
Viewpoint is the majority it could be a
slim majority 52 to 48 it could even be
a ficticious majority polls last week
showed that most Brits don't actually
support this Rwanda plan but yet the
Prime Minister tells us it's the will of
the people my colleague referred to when
the Press owned by right-wing party
political donors produce headlines
declaring High Court judges to be
enemies of the people simply for
requiring Parliament to have its say
when we do that we endanger our
democracy and debate not defend it
populism says nothing shall stand in the
way of the majority opposing views are
now a barrier to the will of the people
so my Representatives on the opposite
side of parliament or on the opposite
side of the council chamber are no
longer just representing people with a
different opinion they are now become
the enemies of the people what does all
this mean well look one side now feels
their Hostage to opposition forces
getting in the way of the will of the
people the other side is made to feel we
don't deserve any
representation just because there happen
to be fewer of us look in a climate like
this both sides turn to hate instead of
debate and that is why we are where we
are mayor that's why we wrote this
amendment we agree with the motion but
there's an Unwritten implication that
this political climate is an unfortunate
storm that's just appeared on our Shores
I tell you it's wrong the political
climate change is very much human
induced thank you
counselor right councelor Williams
please thank you mayor I'll keep my
comments brief uh and I am speaking in
general regarding the original motion
and subsequent amendments received um I
agree with so much of the sentiment
that's been expressed by colleagues but
I have to say the original motion speaks
to a much lar larger issue within
political discourse in the UK today to
my mind it's incumbent upon all of us to
improve the quality of political
discussion and that doesn't only relate
to abuse ridicule and hate it requires
us to uphold in full all of the Nolan
principles for conduct in public life
life for that reason I implore the
conservative group to start practicing
what they are preaching my colleague
councelor Carter has already advised you
earlier this evening councilor Evans how
disappointed she was with the unpleasant
tone of your question regarding private
schools this isn't an isolated incident
a look through Trafford conservatives x
uh or formerly Twitter uh account will
publicly will document a sloy of snide
mocking and unpleasant posts and on a
personal level Council
I have to say I was so appalled at the
posts that were made on that account
following the gmfrs service review and
the decision regarding provision at s
fire station I considered those posts to
be deliberately misleading and an
attempt to promote misinformation this
does nothing to promote confidence in us
as decision makers the public in
Trafford deserve so much better and I
ask that colleagues in the conservative
group rise to that challenge only then
will the quality of political discourse
in the country improve thank you chair
thank you councelor Council Patel
please sorry did you wish to
speak okay thank you does anyone else
wish to
speak yes go ahead
counselor um thank you I I'll keep it
brief that um we were we felt uh
supportive in principle of this uh
Amendment um and of the motion but the
first paragraph of the amendment
uh while noting that it's absolutely
factually correct to say the sharp rise
in hate speech began in 2016 um there's
other wording in that first paragraph
that we felt felt slight somewhat
uncomfortable with supporting and
endorsing uh there's um some aspects
that aren't really uh quite CL quite
clear exactly what they're referring to
uh so we'll be opting to abstain on the
amendment thank you counselor councelor
Evans you have the right to reply
ises this reply to the amendment or the
motion as a whole the
amendment um no I will leave it there
because I think it's clear presuming
people support Council Ross's
proposition that this amendment is going
to fall well I'll address the next
amendment when it pops up thank
you thank you councelor I will now put
the First Amendment to the vote can I
have a show hands please and keep your
hands raised while a record has been
taken all those in
favor thank you all those
against thank thank you any
extensions thank
you the amendment is
lost Amendment two I now invite
councelor Lester to move the amendment
councilor Lester
please thank you mayor um just before we
go to this amendment as well I think we
just like on behalf of the of the green
party to pass on our condolences to uh
to councelor Lloyd's family we never we
never met we didn't meet your husband
unfortunately however I think everybody
all of us need to be a bit more like
Tony and I think this amend this um
motion is sort of is it reflect it's
reflected in this motion I
think um but now back to the our
Amendment um we welcome this motion and
feel that it's actually a really
important motion and we agree with it in
principle but we've put one forward one
simple
Amendment uh we feel that the final
sentence is not in keeping with the in
keeping with the sentiment and the aim
of the motion to use the phrase publicly
condemn is completely contrary to the
spirit of the motion it's an aggressive
terminology which actually encourages ha
hate
speech the sentence also ignores the
fact that not everyone one would feel
safe secure or confident enough to
challenge or publicly condemn abusive
Behavior it could effectively be a
mechanism to encourage pylons particular
in social media or in public
forums we have C we have counselor and
candidate code of codes of conduct and
we feel that people should be using
appropriate disciplinary and legal
mechanisms in response if they are the
recipients of abuse or observe it
happening so because of this we suggest
removing the final
sentence thank you counselor
is that seconded please and you have two
minutes to reply it is second seconded
and I'll reserve the right thank you
very much thank you
counselor the amendment has been moved
in seconded and I invite speakers in
respect of the amendment to combin
speeches on the amendment and the motion
each member wanting to speak will have
only one opportunity to address the
chamber after these speeches I will move
directly to a vote on the amendment and
then without further debat on the vote
on the
emotion do any members wish to speak
please thank you um councelor hard
councel Harding please can you start
thank you thank you mayor I think for me
the section where it mentions the LGA
has launched its debate not hate
Campaign which aims to raise public
awareness of the role of counselors in
their communities encourage healthy
debates and improve the responses and
support for local politicians facing
abuse and intimidation as a female
counselor I have endured incredible
misogyny and it has got worse I am now
um subject I have three men who have uh
a restraining order against them for the
level of abuse that they have directed
at me I have a people turn up at my door
and I wonder whether counselor Holden's
words may come back to haunt him and
this isn't a pop at you councel Holden
but it is a reminder of when you said in
this chamber we don't really need to
bother about redacting because none of
us are that important sadly sadly and
I'm sure some of the other women in this
chamber sorry right well luckily for you
you haven't been subjected to the level
of abuse I have counselor Holden but I'm
sure many I'm speaking I'm sure many
women in this chamber will um stand
shoulder toh shoulder with me and accept
that some of the misogyny that is
leveled at female politicians is
unacceptable I also don't want any of my
colleagues to face any of the abuse that
I have had I think councelor evans's
point was really that it's about we are
entitled to views we are entitled to an
opinions we don't deserve death threats
and that is how serious it can be I was
part of a working group with the LGA and
frankly some of the responses and some
of the stories from counselors was
horrifying really so the spirit of this
motion is that it's about us looking out
for each other it's about us having
healthy debates standing with each other
and if we want good counselors and we
want people to come forward and
represent their communities we should
feel supported to be able to do this
role and express views thank you
thank you councelor Lester
please can I can I respond as the right
to
reply okay thank you go
ahead uh counter Hines
please thank you mayor um and I will be
brief um I did also want to pay my
respects to Tony Lloyd I grew up in um
in a household where I you know I knew
Tony Lloyd be right from being a um a
child is somebody who um has inspired me
um and who I have the utmost respect for
and who is respected in in local
politics and National politics um I also
grew up in a house um where local
democracy was absolutely key and I grew
up in a family with parents who would
regularly remind me really that people
people fought for the right um to vote
that have fought for democracy um and
that we do live and we are looking
enough to live in one of the greatest
democracies in the world um and what I
think in terms of the spirit of this
motion is that if we don't respect that
debate and we're not willing to listen
to the views of others um and and hear
those views we might not always agree
with them but if we can't debate them in
a respectful way then I think we
actually risk that democracy um and so
to the spirit of the motion and all of
the Amendments tonight um you know I
think it's really important um that we
do we do support the um the spirit thank
you thank you counselor councelor frz
please thank you um just on councilor
Harding's point I mean the libdems did
thoroughly support the idea that it's
not right for family and home addresses
to be published online um members of my
group have had people turn up on their
doorstep over the years it's never
really been
appropriate my only concern is that it
we are elected to public office
someone's got to call these things out
and it's it is our responsibility to
call things out publicly that we
disagree with and maybe that's not done
in a personal way there are ways to do
it in our leaflets and our newsletters
it doesn't have to be personal but the
idea that we we don't call out publicly
when we hold public office just did sit
uncomfortably with my group thank
you thank you
councelor councelor Patel
please thank you um representation
matters um the people of Trafford need
to see themselves in their elected
representatives uh we need more people
of minority ethnic backgrounds more
women to come forward into politics uh
thank you to councelor Paul and
councelor Hardin for sharing their
personal stories I'm very sorry to hear
that you've experienced misogynistic and
racist abuse in your role as a
counselor thank you councelor councelor
Taylor
please thank you mayor I wasn't going to
speak on this motion this evening um and
I absolutely support the spirit of the
motion but can I say I find it the
grossest hypocrisy coming from
traitoris because I have actually been
subject to abuse from from you from your
party I am a member of Health scrutiny
which I'm proud to be a member of and I
find it a very uh it's a rewarding
committee and one of the joys of being
on that committee is the interp party
cooperation and respect we have for each
other except when I was made aware that
a question that I legitimately asked
within that committee that regards
Ultram hospital um in the summer of
2022 has been taken out of context T and
used in an abusive way to um infer or
directly state to your followers that I
and our party want to see altringham
hospital closed nothing could be further
from the truth that is an abuse that is
a misrepresentation of me as an
individual asking a legitimate question
in a public forum and it is
misrepresentation of my party to your
followers so yes I do support the Spirit
of this absolutely debate not hate we
are very unlucky as cther very fortunate
as councelor Hines has said to live in a
democracy where we can express our views
and I'm very happy to have a debate with
anybody nobody has to have the same
views as me but what I do take exception
to is
misrepresentation of a legitimate
question asked in a public forum that
regards the spending of public money so
I feel personally I feel
disinclined to support this motion
because of where it comes from thank you
mayor thank you
counselor councilor Lester
please thank you when I come into
politics it it was with the belief that
it should be a safe space and maybe that
was naive of me um but I certainly think
it should be the abuse and attacks that
we see all the time particularly in
social media are shocking and they
certainly don't fit with my values and I
really would hope that of everybody in
this room uh debating and disagreeing
with with one another is a healthy part
of democracy but abuse and intimidation
crosses the line into dangerous
territory and can serve to silence
democracy people from all backgrounds
should feel safe to come into politics
so that all groups are represented both
nationally and locally we need people
from all background but this isn't
currently the case and we've seen
numerous examples of attacks including
dig digital verbal and physical attacks
and this was seen as as its worse and
most serious with the Dreadful murders
of Joe Cox and David
Amos but some groups feel excluded in
many ways and it's time to ensure that
this doesn't happen people with
protected characteristics who are seen
as different are often the recipients of
hate and it needs to stop so for this
reason we do very much welcome this
motion but we also really look forward
to an election campaign with no personal
attacks in it thank you thank you
councelor councelor Evans you have a
right to
reply thank you Madame mayor appreciated
um so I'll go through H councelor Taylor
heard what you say I'll have a I'll
think on it I'll go back and speak to
the team um thank you counc FR for
supporting uh not supporting this
amendment and I will address the
amendment and then I'll do my suming up
uh the green amendment to be fair is
just bizarre
so bizarre in fact that when I I saw it
I thought it was a typo and had to
reread the whole motion a couple of
times to just get my head around where
they were coming from I'll read it
councilors agreed to continually to
promote diversity not unreasonable and
inclusion ahead of the next local
elections exactly what we want beyond
including uh and including uh diversity
of thought of course we want diversity
of thought and then public publicly
condemning politically fueled abusive
Behavior why Would we not want to
condemn it I'm not saying we have to
condemn every single one I'm not saying
we all have to do every single incident
but actually why would we not want to
condemn politically fueled abusive
Behavior so I would urge everybody
including councilor Ross and the labor
group to reject the amendment and take
the uh Motion in the spirit that it is
offered so why was it offered so this
motion came from well our group uh
recommends that new members specifically
new candidates go back over old Council
meetings and actually even tonight we
had candidates due to come to the
gallery to see exactly what goes on
because it can come uh as a bit of a
brutal surprise standing up in here um
and I would
urge all of you to look at our Council
meetings in a about not about the
content of the argument because you some
people over there are never going to
agree with anything I say and probably
vice versa that will happen and actually
I think this debate has probably been
one of the most curtious debates we've
had it's been quite a point to be fair
but go and view some of our old Council
meetings they are horrendous and this
motion has come from potential
candidates say I'm I can't go and stand
in that chamber and have that abuse and
it's in this chamber it isn't about
brexit it isn't about rightwing it isn't
about leftwing or fbpe it is about how
we treat each other that's it so I urge
everybody please condemn abusive
behavior when you see it call it out why
wouldn't you so reject the green emotion
and support please the motion in its
original form in the spirit that it is
offered thank you thank you
counselor I will now put the Second
Amendment to the vote and can I have a
show of hands and please keep your hands
raised while a record is taken all those
in
favor
all those
against any
extensions
the Second Amendment is carried thank
you since we have already had a
substantial discussion I propose without
any further debate to move to the vote
of the substan of motion please I will
now put a substantial motion to the vote
and can I have a show of hands please
and keep your hands raised while a
record is taken all those in
favor
thank you all those
against any
abstentions the motion is carried thank
you
motion 7B the next motion this evening
is for the city of sanctuary and is to
be moved by Council Axford
please amidst the darkness and Gloom of
the hostile environment created by this
government towards refugees and Asylum
Seekers I welcome this motion's glimmer
of hope and positivity becoming a member
of city of sanctu UK means that Trafford
commits to be a place of sanctuary
recognizing that those fleeing
persecution human rights violations Wars
the catastrophic effects of climate
change are welcome supported and fully
integrated into our community
recognizing their invaluable
contribution it also means Trafford
commits to to an action plan to embed
Sanctuary Concepts across Council
services and The Wider community and
works with other local authorities to
challenge this government's inhumane
practices and to enable social
change just imagine after having waited
for so long your life in limbo with just
£ 4739 a week to live off in off an
inadequate home office accommodation you
finally have your Refugee application
approved and you now have a legal right
to live in the
UK but along with this long awaited news
comes your eviction with just 28 days to
find somewhere to live find an income
through work or benefits and open a bank
account and from September to December
last year this was shockingly reduced
just s days thankfully the government
quietly reversed this decision after the
ensuing
chaos without the resources to secure
private accommodation you're dependent
on your local Authority housing you but
in the government's rush to clear the
backlog of refugee applications a bed
every night is overloaded so unless you
have additional needs you may have no
choice but to sleep on the streets or on
a blowup bed in a communal room as a
welfare rights adviser I helped many
refug refes claimed benefits in order to
take their first steps towards becoming
fully integrated citizens in the UK many
took out work with poor conditions such
as an in an Amazon
warehouse I was so impressed with their
commitment to lead a better life than
the tormented one they've Left Behind
surely people who' have taken such huge
risks face such huge coun pleas and
overcome so many obstacles in making
their way to the UK should be welcomed
with the respect and compassion they
deserve please support this motion thank
you thank you thank you councelor can
the motion be seconded please and you
have two minutes to speak thank you
thank you mayor um I'll be as brief as I
can exactly a month from this day on the
New Year Eve when the rest of the world
was preparing to celebrate the beginning
of a new year sadly two places in
particular in the same world were bombed
and you know people were killed on New
Year's Eve alone Russian air strikes hit
the Ukrainian city of K injuring at
least 28 people and damaging Residential
Building including hotels and schools
on the same night 100 people were killed
in Gaza and in the same night 20 more
people were killed in alaka University
where people were you know taking
Refuge at least 26,000 gazin have lost
their lives since the conflict has
escalated and more than 10,000 civilians
are killed in Ukraine by the Russian
invasion the violence continues and
there is no sign of stopping a
parliamentary report shows that the UK
export of arms has doubled in the recent
times and shamefully this government is
equally responsible for the killing of
innocent people in such conflicts the
British prime minister and his team have
bled on their hands this government has
intentionally and purposely failed to
play its vital role in bringing peace in
the conflicted zones those who survive
have no homes to go back to they either
become internally displaced people or
refugees nationally this government has
failed to protect the rights of Asylum
Seekers who flee their homes in search
for safety instead they have been
demonized and portrayed a threat to our
economy and
services the government has taken away
million from our Council
alone and this has faced us you know
facing problems and difficulties yet
they had 290 million to spend on the
failed Randa Asylum process as of June
last year there is a case load of
pending Asylum case is about quarter of
a
million the long delays are making the
vulnerable more vulnerable majority of
these Asylum Seekers and refugees are
normal people with transferable skills
and qualification which can be utilized
can you finish up please therefore I'm
supporting the motion thank you thank
you the motion has been moved and
seconded do any members wishing to speak
and if you do so you have one minute
each thank
you
councelor
broy I wholeheartedly agree with this
motion and just like to add a few
comments my mother was a teacher in
Manchester and for many years taught
English as a second language she worked
teaching English to refugees escaping
Vietnam in the 1980s at the time they
were called boat people as they'd come
to our country seeking Refuge VI boats
rhetoric was so different now as overall
our country then welcomed this group of
people at the time in the 1980s most
people supported their integration I was
a student working for the Vietnamese
Club in leads and we provided transport
and the ability for people to socialize
it was an enriching and an informative
experience for me to fast forward to
2024 how things are different now so I'm
a member of the church in Ultram that
supports the Ultram Hub mentioned the
motion frequently on a Sunday I sit
alongside these people and I hear their
moving stories and how they can't return
to their previous countries their
experience of the British system is both
enlightening and alarming on the one
hand the welcome support and sanctuaries
of our community Faith organizations
that support them and their families is
something to be proud of everyone who's
part of this support network is enriched
by the experience but on the other hand
there is this darker side of British
culture that is unfortunately inflamed
by this current thank you coun can you
finish up please so in in finishing up
please support the motion by this we can
send a powerful message of Welcome to
vulnerable people seeking sanuy here
thank you mayor thank you councelor
councelor certain
please uh thank you uh the circumstances
that force people to flee their homes
and their home countries in order to
save their lives are never disconnected
from the economic injustices driven by
supposedly developed countries and by
the excesses of capitalism uh nor is any
of this disconnected from the impacts of
climate cycles and balances breaking
down at at an increasingly terrifying
right the green party will always stand
up proudly and give clear unambiguous
support for refugees and other migrants
um along with my ward colleagues were
particularly proud of how hail residents
reacted when news emerged that the
Ashley Hotel was to be used to house
Asylum Seekers overwhelming the response
was one of compassion an understanding
of the depths of horror these
individuals have experienced an
awareness they are now victims of a
broken Asylum system a system broken
systematically as political Choice the
small numbers who attempted to stop
Division and fear found themselves
hopelessly outnumbered by humankindness
of course we're going to be supporting
this motion wholeheartedly but we need
much so much more we need safe roots for
refugees we need an asylum seek system
that treats people with dignity and
respect we need comprehensive Rootin
Branch reform of the home office thank
you councelor councelor lug
please thank you mayor I have to declare
an interest in uh in this motion perhaps
my surname is a hint as to that interest
it isn't very British is it it was
anglicized perhaps poorly so when my
family arrived on boats I like several
counselors in this chamber come from an
immigrant family my grand
great-grandparents generation fled
Central Europe they had no destination
in mind just to escape to survive what
eventually would become come the final
solution I always been keenly aware that
the sanctuary this country offered my
family not only granted me the freedom
to stand here but to Simply exist at
all that very Sanctuary a literal
Lifeline to past Generations has been
Stripped Away by our current government
in clear breach of international laws
the cynical weaponization of refugees by
this government is sickening to me as I
would hope it to would be to all of you
and I am happy to support this motion
thank you thank you councelor good
timing councelor Hines please thank you
may um when I watch the news at night I
often think about my two teenage
children um and who are actually really
young adults and how if they were facing
persecution if they were facing conflict
how I would want them to find themselves
if they were fleeing that conflict in a
place place where that they were
supported and where there was a culture
of Welcome inclusion and empowerment for
them to grow and prosper that is what I
would want for my children and I welcome
the opportunity for us to build on the
on the on the culture that we've already
begun to create in Trafford thank you
mayor thank you councelor councelor mins
please thank you mayor
my parents aren't UK born and they don't
come from the wealthy end of of Indian
Society my father was born in India
moved to compal in Uganda as a toddler
he was disabled had Polio he affected
both of his legs as idam Min Rose
through the ranks my grandmother could
see what was coming she sent her husband
to the UK to work when it was getting
dangerous as a disabled children were
going Indian children were were soon to
become the first victims of the regime
she fled with her two teen te AG Sons
the difference between them and the
people fleeing persecution nowadays is
that my grandp parents had British
passports from the colonial era the two
children traveled on the mother's
passport when in Cala my my grandparents
often didn't have food for or clothing
for the family my father attended a
street school where the teacher a
science teacher from the local school
offered free education after his working
day to the street children these
children were so or they would wear a
sheet to school as it were the scho
street school because their parents
couldn't afford thank you coun can you
finish up please thank
you it it demonstrates this country has
been a place that welcomes people fing
persecution but with the current
government and how they behave and
uttering in in in enacting ut utterly
appalling policies my late father and
his parents would not recognize the
country that they came to thank you
counselor councelor h first
please um tonight I'm speaking in
support of the city of sanctuary
motion my daughter recently did some
work with the Jewish Museum in
Manchester where she looked at the
stories of Jewish refugees in the second
world war one of these was Alice
grandmother of a Trafford resident Laura
and to save her life her family put
Alice on Kinder transport to the UK but
once here she only escaped internment
because she was too young I also learned
about Valley a Jewish German citizen who
managed to access the UK on a domestic
service visa she wasn't allowed to bring
her family with her and they were all
killed while she cared for British
people sometimes it feels like things
haven't changed very much I'd like to
tell you about my foster son Sam at 13
He Walked 4,000 miles to find his only
surviving family here in the UK there
was no safe route for him he's a typical
teenage boy he loves Cricket his mobile
phone and ice cream and he dreams of
becoming an engineer so he can go home
and rebuild his country
on one visit to the war museum he
pointed a tank out to me and told me a
similar one had killed his neighbor I
say some's a typical teenager but he's
also a boy who's experienced huge coun
can you finish please thank you I'm just
saying I want to support this motion
because it commits to welcoming and
supporting refugees and stands up to the
government's hostile environment and
persecution of people who are just the
same as us except they are not safe at
home thank you counselor councelor Ross
please thank you Mar it's a privilege to
follow councilor Hurst there with some
some amazing work that she does to
support vulnerable people and welcome
them into this uh country so thank you
um it's been quite a sober evening so
far we've discussed International
situations we've discussed some of the
experiences that colleagues have had in
the room and I am so sorry to hear about
the racist abuse that people have felt
including yourself councelor poor it is
unacceptable I wanted to look at a
positive in terms of what Trafford has
done and how Trafford has led the way in
the past and I'm going to go back to um
almost a decade ago and St monikas uh
the Roman Catholic um Parish of St
monikas in uh in flixton who um with
Caritas instigated the first of the
sponsorship families for the UK as part
of the sponsored Refugee scheme that was
an amazing experience and you have seen
that family flourish and grow and have a
restaurant in the locality it shows the
very best of Trafford it shows the very
best of our community in Trafford and I
think this is a natural extension of
that and I'm very proud that we are
moving this today thank
you thank you councelor Ross council
laxford do you have a right to reply
please and sorry Council R go ahead
you've got a
minute thank you Madame mayor I'll be
brief um we won't be supporting this
we'll be abstaining on this I think it
it it Paints the country and it paints
Trafford in uh an unacceptable light
frankly um so it is a virtue signal it
sadly implies that we have a Bor have
not being welcoming many Community here
we go you see here we go many Community
groups schools churches volunteers all
ENC the all encompassing statements
within this they could be offended we
have been welcoming and for a country
you've knocked a government that is the
ninth globally for receiving refugees
the UK is the top one in is the second
in Europe second only to Sweden um and
recently largest influx of genuine
assign has been those fleeing war in
Ukraine been very and we've all been
very involved in that work and proud of
what we've done with the Afghan refugees
the 800 Hong kongers that are here in
Trafford and I will Echo councelor Evans
can you finish up please we have claimed
4 million pound from the government to
build a site for refugees in altringham
we have a culture of welome we would be
ninth in the world and we wouldn't be
second in Europe thank
you councilor Axford please you have a
right to
reply um yeah just briefly thank you for
your support I'm I'm really sorry that
youve decided to abstain from this the
motion does clearly state that um it
being a city being a a local authority
of St will actually build on what we're
already doing so I really hope you can
vote for the motion thank you thank you
than you
[Music]
councelor I will now put the motion to
the vote and can I have a show of hands
please and keep your hands raised while
a record has been taken all those in
favor all those
against any
extensions thank you motion is carried
thank
you motion 7 C the next motion this
evening is about Local Government
funding and is to be moved by councelor
hary please Council thank you mayor uh
mindful of the time can I just check how
long you wish me to speak for
sorry can I just check how long you you
want to speak for mon thank you counc
two minutes okay thank you my time and
again I've called for a fair funding
deal for Trafford not preferential
treatment just a fair share compared to
other authorities time and again I've
called on local conservatives to
publicly echo my call and time and again
they failed to do so each time they let
Trafford residents downless we forget
the damage the conservatives did to the
council's finances and to Frontline
Services when they led the council
council tax Frozen depriving the council
of50 million in its council tax base sh
start centers closed Council Care Homes
closed on this side of the chamber we in
labor have balanced the budget each year
whilst looking after residents through
covid and protecting Frontline services
at the start of the year we had another
budget Gap to close of 20 million we've
reduced this down to 6.4 million and
waited with baited breath to see if the
government leveled up Trafford in the
Autumn statement but nothing no new
funding to help plug the gaps council's
face just before Christmas another
one-year funding settlement for local
government the maximum council tax
increase baked in again as an assumption
overnight the remaining budget gap for
Trafford increased to 7.2 million on two
months notice before we're supposed to
set a balanced budget this is no way to
treat a council and it's no way to treat
trafficed residents 40 conservative MP
40 conservative MP P finally woke up to
the fact that for 14 years their
governments have been systematically
cutting Council budgets and local
services and they call on the Prime
Minister for more funding and behold at
the 11th Hour the Secretary of State
suddenly finds another 500 million pound
down the back of his sofa 500 million
against the 4 billion needed just so
councils can stand still no word on
whether this is one off or recurring no
word on next year settlement less than
one month before we're due to agree the
council budget forgive me if I say this
does not reassure and forgive me if I
never trust a conservative to have the
interests of local government or our
Trafford residents at heart those 40
tour MPS finally understand but none of
our local tourist do so gr Brady hasn't
signed the letter I've never known any
local conservative to publicly call Fair
funding
settlement I say to all members in this
chamber do your duty stand by Trafford
residents call for a fair funding deal
for Trafford and support this motion
thank you thank you is the motion
seconded
please thank you councelor
Hart thank you mayor um so I thought I
would take us on a little trick down
memory lane and sadly we're not going to
be pouring over lovely photographs and
recounting joyful Tales this isn't an
episode of the good old days it's called
never-ending austerity measures so let
us start with 2011 shall we the then
Tory leader St stated it's not about
stopping services but about providing
iding them in a different way as budget
proposals table slashing 8.7 million
from communities and well-being 6
million from children and young people
Services 2.7 from environment transport
and operations the list goes on 2012
shall we visit Trafford council is to
cut 180 jobs and ask staff to Take 5
days onp paid leave a year as part of 34
million budget savings the conservative
L Authority but coalition government
let's not forget that has also also
revealed it is closing 10 of its 16
children's centers to meet the savings
between April 2013 and
15 the Conservative then leader stated
this Trafford has reduced finances
through achieving Innovation and
sometimes groundbreaking efficiencies
across all our services remind me again
how Innovative closing children census
has been 2014 yet more another long list
youth censors in Partington Davy hum
lost St 30 to 37 school crossing patrols
cut parking fees increased allotment
fees raised funding for illuminated
Christmas decorations cut fast forward
to 2016 the same you're getting the
picture here and on we go and here we
are in 2024 an utter mess councelor
chakrabati recently thanked the Prime
Minister when he visited Ultram for
securing funds to repair potholes for to
resurface the rolls and cinderland Road
had been mentioned yet on all of your
leaflets it's the fault of this labor
Council that aren't repairing the roads
so which is it can we go back to rishy
and say please sir can we have some more
because that's how it's become we
desperately want to fill those po
councel Harding can you finish up please
thank you yes the council has seen
realterm cuts and we have been overly
reliant on a really regressive thing
which is called council tax which falls
back on our hardworking families during
the cost of living crisis this current
funding model is broken and it breaks
things for our residents the people we
all represent I just want to repeat
councelor Harley's plea to all members
of this chamber do your duty stand by
Trafford residents call for a fair
funding deal for Trafford and support
this motion thank
you amendment I have received a notice
of an amendment to the motion and I
invite councelor FR to move just please
thank
you thank you mayor uh why are we doing
this amendment why are we all here well
I'd like to think every everyone here
cares about local government liberals
believe in decision- making at the
lowest possible level power should be
shared spread devolved not hoarded at
the top that's why we care so much about
local councils and local elections but I
don't think this government cares about
local councils they seem to act as if
it's all a bit beneath them the last
minute pots of money dished out last
week quite literally an afterthought you
know it's the first thing though that
Springs to mind when they're looking for
those all important efficiency savings
but I wonder are we all in it together
when hunt became Chancellor during all
that turmoil he cut the banking sear
charge 18 billion going back to Big
Banks is that um is that an efficiency
saving do we know we've been saying for
some time at budget scrutiny we've got
to come up with something different to
make this government fix the broken
funding formula I don't know if graah
Brady's still listening but he knows the
difficulty Trafford is in why would
won't Brady tell sunak Trafford is not
getting a fair deal maybe he thinks
rishy will just laugh and walk off
wouldn't be the first time but we
mustn't forget there is a government in
waiting I I do want to know how labor
are going to fix that broken funding
formula now I've said that before and I
was reminded quite rightly there are 63
of us and we all have a duty to make the
case so what the lib dem's doing well
look we know early day motions aren't
going to become law but they do show the
level of support for different ideas in
Parliament so final three points mayor
this EDM 67 it's from the north
shopshire libdem it's getting cross
party signatures labor MPS have signed
it already libd MPS Trafford MPS should
add their names to this if they can in
Parliament to show it's something we
it's important to us back home here in
Trafford libdems are supporting the
motion I hope that we can add this
amendment thank you thank you uh is the
amendment
seconded thank you mayor we've all
become very used to short-termism in the
way that national government treats
local councils that has been the case
since long before the pandemic and it
has gotten worse with each passing year
and each passing Tory prime minister
long gone are the days when governments
allowed our chief finance officer to
plan around Financial settlement several
years in advance we've become accustomed
to living year by year or even month by
month with the Tories in Westminster
throwing just enough Crumbs from the
table once in a while to Stave off calls
for real funding reform now I'm sure
that Tori miners will hope that by
hurriedly announcing some last minute
cash for councils last week they've
deflected the blame from themselves from
the crisis which councils up and down
the country find themselves in but I
think we should be clear about that
announcement because the local
government Association has said that to
Stave off the collapse of councils
across England the figure needed from
central government is one and a half
billion the Tories have given just a
third of that figure less than a month
before we were expected to set our
budget it's tokenistic infantilizing and
disrespectful of our officers and of the
residents that we serve to treat local
government Finance as an afterthought
councils are still the front line in our
society in so many ways even after a
decade and a half of cuts and when there
is a crisis it's councils which are best
placed to step in but the reality is
Madame mayor that councils rise to those
challenges despite this government not
because of help from this government and
if we were a fairly funded Council we
could do so much more on preventing
poverty on creating opportunity and on
helping people to live healthier lives
but a cynic would have to conclude that
the conservatives don't really care
about local government at all why else
would they strip Trafford of 60% of its
core spending power compared with 13
years ago why else would they ask our
residents to accept higher council tax
in return for declining services so not
only should we pass this motion tonight
but when the opportunity arises to make
Trapper's case in Parliament the MPS who
represent us there should add their
names every single time and that's what
we wish to achieve with this amendment
thank
you thank you
counselor the amendment has been moved
and seconded and I invite speakers in
respect of the amendment to combine
speeches on the amendment and the motion
each member wanting to speak will have
an only one opportunity to address the
chamber after these speeches I will move
directly to a vote on the amendment and
then without further debate on the vote
of the
motion council is wishing to speak can
you raise your hands
please
for
thank
you councel Harley have one minute
please all speakers have just one minute
thank you mayor I'm uh Rising just to
speak uh in relation to the amendment
moved by the liberal Democrat group and
just to make it clear the labor group
will not be accepting that Amendment uh
there are two main reasons for that one
is that the two Trafford labor members
of parliament both have Shadow
ministerial appointments and therefore
are unable to sign an early day motion
the second reason is one uh of more
substance about the content of the early
day motion one of the things that it
notes is the increasing pressure on
local councils to make precarious
Investments to protect essential
Services I think that's consistent
really with the position the libd group
have adopted regarding Council
Investments uh they've not been involved
in the investment board other decisions
that the council have made here in
Trafford we make prudent investment
decisions the council's professionally
advised on that and those investment
decisions are crucial for two reasons
one they generate more income for the
council at a time when it's desperately
needed and two they allow us to drive
our regeneration objectives for the Bure
so for that reason the labor group will
be voting against the amendment thank
you thank you counselor counselor Taylor
please thank you mayor Trafford council
is under acute Financial pressure and is
being forced to make decisions about
funding allocation that no Authority
should ever have to
contemplate the historical failure to
address inequitable Council funding
systems has led to Trafford residents
being severely disadvantaged compared
with residents in other local
authorities let us be absolutely clear
where the blame for the perilous
financial situation Trafford finds
itself in comes from it is with this
failed rancid Tor government 14 years of
ideologically driven austerity soaring
inflation and costs have meant that
trafford's finances have been cut to the
Bone every means of investment
Innovation saving and cutting have been
implemented to stay afloat but there is
no more to take now councils are being
incentivized to dispose of assets
libraries buildings land to store
restore Revenue budget which is simply
Taylor can you finish up literally
selling the family sver at a time when
the economy is
tanked they need to have properly funded
taxation with not with unsustainable
short-term fixes the council's scraping
around for funding yet this Government
Can you finish up please thank you
terrible waste fundamental funding
reform is needed urgently thank you
mayor please support the motion thank
you councilor Evans please thank you
Madame mayor um let me take you on a
trip down memory
lane we uh all supported our staff and
we all took 82% put in this chamber to
support our staff and we all know how
badly that ended councelor Harding
however um we have in the past been
members of the t40 we've campaigned for
that for years and and actually as a
group we were notionally inclined uh to
support this because there is uh some
substance to it but actually um you have
a go freezing the council tax I think
our group is proud to freeze the council
tax for our residents at that time you
remember that wasn't for the council
that was for the residents and the
residents appreciated it they do
appreciate things like that rather than
Rises um I think you lost us at a 40%
pay rise guys you lost us at the
politicization of the council's uh
Communications Department last week so
we'll be abstaining on this one thank
you Council Evans councel Welton
please thank you mayor um we've heard a
lot about respect tonight respect um
paying our respects to Tony Lloyd um
respect for political opponents and
respect for refugees and migrants now we
have to ask central government to
respect local government by funding it
properly we reject the double standards
of a government that boast about
reducing Progressive relatively
Progressive taxes on a national level
whilst expecting councils to make above
inflation increases in council tax
council tax is one of the most
regressive taxes that our residents have
to P have to pay and the conservatives
have done nothing about reforming it we
reject the flip-flop approach to funding
that leaves our Council stripped to
vital grants in December only to receive
some crumbs of compensation in January
due due to the conservatives internal
political Strife where is the
professionalism how are our offices
supposed to plan in this environment and
finally we absolutely reject Michael
Go's plan to fill the funding to fill
the funding Hole by pressurizing
councils to sell off their valued
buildings and assets whether delivering
our Vital services and quality of life
to their residents I'm nearly finished
or earning additional Revenue the future
of our libraries and town halls and our
Capital Investments must be decided
not by
whiteall right the rest of the speakers
we're reducing the time to 30 seconds
can you please be precise as possible
thank you councelor Thomas please thank
you may i' been more respectful than the
last speaker at your request to finish
let's look at the facts Trafford have
lost 60% of government funding since 210
freezing a council tax between 2010 and
15 has cost us Circa 15 million in this
year's budget consequences of these
these actions are undue and unnecessary
presses on key Council Services offering
support for the most vulnerable in C in
traffic Trafford is not a political
Flagship for people to play with by
holding and freezing council tax it's to
Bright we are now a council provid
upmost Services support this motion
thank you councelor Jones
please yeah thank you chair I just like
to go back to the November meeting going
back in time uh Council Evans quipped
that we could would find 20,000 be down
the
sofa in the crumbs there's no crumbs
left and soon there be no sofa because
we'll have to sell a sofa as assets so I
don't think the conservative group
actually take this seriously all all
councilors need to stand up and support
this fed fund motion and it's really
disappointing they've decided to abstain
thank you thank you counselor councelor
Carter
please thank you mayor um Trafford
increased members sorry Trafford members
enjoy allowances to shock horror the
lowest level across tenur in Greater
Manchester as a successful businessman
Trafford conservatives leader may not
care at all about the equalities
argument cited by the reviewer for the
uplift allowances but riddle me this why
if you're campaigning weekly about the
trousering of new allowances have you
and all your Tory members all trousered
said new allowances it would take a 20
second email to say you didn't wish to
take the uplift but youve
mons hands up if you haven't taken the
allance
increase councelor Ross please well I
see no hands going up so clearly they
have taken that money and I think that's
an absolute disgrace the online abuse
that the rest of us have had even this
morning on my own Twitter feed from your
shower your Trafford conservative group
saying about us taking that uplift from
an independent panel you've taken the
lot and you have deceived the public
with that
thank you Council
Ross Council Patel please Local
Government funding is complex and it's
incumbent on us all to help residents
understand it instead traffic Tories are
engaged in a campaign of misinformation
telling residents ring fence grant money
we receive for regen or active travel
projects could be spent on road repairs
uh claiming happy to receive an uplift
and claiming it's the reason why we're
struggling convenient overlooking the
millions and millions of pounds we have
lost and the millions of pounds we still
need to cut over future years so next
time you're all pointing at a pothole
you should take the time to look in a
mirror
too councelor Harley you have a right to
reply you've got 30 seconds please uh
thank you may well councel rans has
renaged on the spirit of the motion that
he moved just half an hour ago already
encouraging a pylon by propagating
misleading information when he knows the
true circumstance es of how that
increase in counselor allowances came
about and they've accepted that pay rise
themselves absolute hypocrisy I'm
pleased that the lids and the green
groups are as I understand that are
going to support the motion um we just
hope that the government take action and
if they don't that there is a change of
government that will properly fund and
value local councils like Trafford thank
you thank you councelor I will now put
the amendment to the vote and can I ask
a show of hands to keep your hands
raised while the a record has been taken
please all those in
favor
sorry
sorry the amendment to the vote please
all those in
favor thank you all all those
against
any
extensions thank
you the amendment is
lost since we've had since we have
already had a substantial discussion I
propose without any further debate to
move to the vote on the substan of
motion and I will now put the substan of
motion to the vote and can I have a show
of hands and please keep your hands
raised while a record is taken thank you
all those in
[Music]
favor all those
against
any
abstentions the motion is carried thank
you this ends the
meeting and thank you thank you all for
your attendance and J invitation to join
me in the Parlor if you're wishing to do
so for some
refreshments thank you
everybody
s